[Music]
[Music]
the earliest time measurements were
observations of cycles of the natural
world using patterns of changes from day
to night and season to season to build
calendars more precise timekeeping like
sundials and mechanical clocks
eventually came along to put time in
more convenient boxes but what exactly
is it that we're measuring is time
something that physically exists or is
it just in our heads at first the answer
seems obvious of course time exists it
constantly unfolds all around us and
it's hard to imagine the universe
without it but our understanding of time
started getting complicated thanks to
Einstein his theory of relativity tells
us that time passes for everyone but
doesn't always pass at the same rate for
people in different situations like
those traveling close to the speed of
light or orbiting a supermassive black
hole
Einstein resolved the malleability of
time by combining it with space to
define space-time which can bend but
behaves in consistent predictable ways
Einstein's theory seemed to confirm that
time is woven into the very fabric of
the universe but there's a big question
it didn't fully resolve why is it we can
move through space in any direction but
through time in only one no matter what
we do the past is always stubbornly
behind us this is called the arrow of
time when a drop of food coloring is
dropped into a glass of water we
instinctively know that the coloring
will drift out from the drop ventually
filling the glass imagine watching the
opposite happen here we'd recognize time
as unfolding back
we live in a universe where the food
coloring spreads out in the water not a
universe where it collects together in
physics this is described by the second
law of thermodynamics which says that
systems will gain disorder or entropy
over time systems in our universe move
from order to disorder and it is that
property of the universe that defines
the direction of times arrow so if time
is such a fundamental property it should
be in our most fundamental equations
describing the universe right we
currently have two sets of equations
that govern physics general relativity
describes the behavior of very large
things while quantum physics explains
the very small one of the biggest goals
in theoretical physics over the last
half century has been reconciling the
two into one fundamental theory of
everything there have been many attempts
none yet proven and they treat time in
different ways oddly enough one
contender called the wheeler DeWitt
equation doesn't include time at all
like all current theories of everything
that equation is speculative but as a
thought experiment if it or a similarly
time-starved equation turned out to be
true would that mean that time doesn't
exist at the most fundamental level
could time just be some sort of illusion
generated by the limitations of the way
we perceive the universe we don't yet
know but maybe that's the wrong way of
thinking about it instead of asking if
time exists as a fundamental property
maybe it could exist as an emergent one
emergent properties are things that
don't exist in individual pieces of a
system but do exist for the system as a
whole
each individual water molecule doesn't
have a tide but the whole ocean does a
movie creates change through time by
using a series of still images that
appear to have a fluid continuous change
between them flipping through the images
fast enough our brains perceive the
passage of time
from the sequence of still images no
individual frame of the movie changes or
contains the passage of time but it's a
property that comes out of how the
pieces are strung together the movement
is real yet also an illusion could the
physics of time somehow be a similar
illusion physicists are still exploring
these and other questions
so we're far from a complete explanation
at least for the moment if time does
exist you'll probably want a brief
history of it explore more of the
fundamental questions of our existence
by downloading a free audio version of
Stephen Hawking's modern classic at
audible.com slash ted-ed
every trial created encourages audible
to continue supporting Ted Ed's
nonprofit mission